yeah so
you know i heart radio um is back after
being canceled last year
uh what can you expect this year
well we're just having live events live
music live concerts are back i think we
the fans and the artists are feeling
that enthusiasm and excitement i do know
uh that you know coldplay and duality
billy eilige olivia rodrigo just some of
the artists that are here with us are
very amped up to get on the stage and
feel the vibrations of people and feel
the energy of a crowd and that's what
they do that that's in their dna they
they want to feel
and see reaction from people performing
uh this is a huge show it's two nights
all walks of life all genres of music
and then we also in between the two
nights to a concert in the middle of the
day here in las vegas
how do you come up with the lineup and
also do you have any any last minute
surprise performances i know sometimes
there's kind of like a last minute
guest to kind of uh join some of the
artists when they're on stage
yeah the artists that are here are
really the most requested most played
the most listened to artists on ir radio
throughout the year and that's on all of
our stations pop stations country
stations doesn't matter what the station
format is if you're big and you're
played a lot then you're here at this
show which is great and they've all said
they won't be here so that's that's fun
um i i think that uh
we pride ourselves on putting together a
big show
with a plan but we also aren't so rigid
that if our
just
produced something at the last minute we
let them go do it so we'll have a
collaboration that just came together
with nellie in florida georgia line
they've got they've worked together
a couple of times and who knows by the
time this is over maybe something else
will happen
awesome that's awesome well obviously
the lineup looks amazing um
exciting obviously the festival is very
exciting for for the fans but also for
the artists themselves i mean because
i'm assuming that this is a great way to
like network and if they don't really
know each other um on
like on a personal base this is a great
place to do it like you said maybe kind
of you know spark up some projects down
the road
it's happened before where artists uh
you would think they all talk to each
other all the time or they see each
other all the time uh sure they can dm
each other
it's very rare that they're in the same
place at the same time maybe an award
show but
that you don't have that vibe here
because they're not competing they're
just having fun and hanging out and so
ideas collaborations future tracks are
born out of those moments uh maybe the
next top 40 hit will come out of two
artists that we don't know about they're
here tonight
that's awesome uh the festival obviously
has been going on for 10 years uh did
you envision it this way back when it
started to what it is now
i remember when the idea was being
talked about at iheart and i just kept
hearing we're gonna make it bigger than
anything else more artists than anybody
else and we're gonna make it fun and
we're gonna do it basically for two days
straight and i thought that's great but
can we maintain that and get well we get
enough artists to want to do that and
sure enough after the first one
took off uh
people wanted to be at the second one
and the third one and now over a decade
has gone by and we're still here and
fortunately we're here to see each other
in person which is the biggest news of
all that's awesome
um
what celebrity what song what are you
looking forward to what's like the best
thing that you're kind of you know
excited for for this weekend for this
festival
i sing along to all of these songs when
i'm playing them on the air
when people can't hear me before i open
the mic to talk but i was just singing
remember cheap trick from back in the
day i don't know if you do enough but
they've they're here they've been making
albums for
forever and uh i was just singing one of
the songs called the flame which i
remember slow dancing to in junior high
school like this it was just giving me a
walk down memory lane because i wasn't
even promised like pre-prom so we were
dancing
like that the rock
back and forth so i i don't know i might
see
ernie tonight but please not on camera
awesome awesome well obviously you know
there's never um
and there's never a bad idea to to be
here in vegas anything that you like to
do when you're out here in vegas
eat i think there's so many great
restaurants i'm a foodie so there are so
many great restaurants uh it's i don't
have enough
meals to get to all the places where i
want to eat but i literally was walking
to the hotel today saying i've got to
come back on a food tour i don't i mean
there are so many things to do but for
me it's all of the most amazing
restaurants from around the country here
in glen city
yeah no for sure for sure i've been here
for about uh eight months now and
my list keeps growing and growing and
growing from all the restaurants and my
pants i mean it's everything is just
kind of getting tired
yeah i know i don't blame you this is a
great place um a shortage of opportunity
there oh yeah definitely definitely well
thank you so much i appreciate it i'm
looking forward to this and have a great
weekend it's going to be amazing
thanks thanks for talking to me take
care bye you too